>> Will Sentance: Thật dân gian, đó là công việc tuyệt vời trong hai ngày qua.
Lòng biết ơn to lớn đối với từng người mà tôi đã kêu gọi trong suốt chặng đường.
Ai biết nếu bạn biết điều đó sẽ đến.
Nhưng trời ơi, nếu bạn không biết, [LAUGH] đó là chuyến đi như thế nào.
Nhưng đó là một niềm vui tuyệt đối.
Chúng tôi đã xem qua, hãy tóm tắt ngắn gọn.
Chúng tôi đã xem xét các nguyên tắc cơ bản của JavaScript mà bạn đã thấy,
họ không bao giờ đi xa.
[LAUGH] Họ đã ở trên nền tảng.
Sau đó, chúng tôi đã thấy một phần thú vị tạo nên một phần cốt lõi của chức năng
lập trình, các hàm bậc cao hơn của chúng tôi, khả năng để lại chỗ dành sẵn cho
một số chức năng trong một chức năng và sau đó chỉ xác định chức năng đầy đủ
một khi chúng ta chạy hàm và điều đó khá hay, một phần của lập trình hàm.
Hoặc có thể tôi thậm chí sẽ nói thực sự nơi bạn có thể lấy những thứ này.
Nếu bạn muốn tìm hiểu thêm về điều đó, vì có rất nhiều chức năng bạn có thể
chỉnh sửa, đặc biệt là chỉnh sửa mạnh mẽ nhất trong số tất cả, giảm, thực sự đẹp,
tất cả đều có trong các bộ phận Hall lập trình chức năng.
Tôi sẽ cung cấp cho bạn một số theo dõi nhỏ về những thứ ở đây.
Sau đó, chúng tôi giải quyết vấn đề đối với tôi là tính năng đẹp nhất của JavaScript, vì nó
như kiểu, wow, nếu tôi hiểu, tôi thực sự nhận được mô hình thực thi của JavaScript.
Ý tưởng rằng một hàm trên thực tế có thể trả về mã đã lưu vào một toàn cục khác
nhãn và điều đó sẽ mang lại dữ liệu với nó
ba lô của anh ấy mà sau đó chúng tôi có quyền sử dụng trong suốt thời gian còn lại, vĩnh viễn,
bạn sẽ khám phá ra rằng bạn có thể sử dụng nó ở mọi nơi.
Điều đó chi phối các công việc mà chúng ta không hề hay biết.
Sau đó, chúng tôi đã thấy JavaScript không đồng bộ trong vòng lặp sự kiện.
Đây là điều tôi muốn tìm hiểu sâu hơn giống như chúng ta đã thấy toàn bộ
mô hình của JavaScript không đồng bộ, thành thật mà nói, chúng tôi đã vượt xa JavaScript.
Đó là JavaScript chạy trong trình duyệt web, vì vậy chúng tôi phải đưa tất cả
những thứ khác ở đây mà JavaScript cung cấp cho chúng tôi quyền truy cập.
Và họ có một loạt các quy tắc về cách nội dung đó kết thúc trên web
trình duyệt, giống như nói chuyện với bộ đếm thời gian cũ trên Internet,
cho phép chức năng liên quan của nó mà nó sẽ chạy khi hoàn thành.
Và dữ liệu có thể lấy lại từ công việc nền đó,
trở lại JavaScript.
Có một số theo dõi về những thứ xung quanh những thứ như chuỗi lời hứa,
các lĩnh vực khác, xây dựng lời hứa từ đầu.
Nhưng thú vị để theo dõi vào.
Và cuối cùng, chúng ta đã thấy ở đây các lớp, nguyên mẫu, chuỗi nguyên mẫu,
thuộc tính proto không phải là thuộc tính nguyên mẫu,
[LAUGH] nhưng có liên kết đến thuộc tính nguyên mẫu.
Chúng tôi đã thấy cách mới và điều khoản không thay đổi bất kỳ điều gì bên cạnh
tự động hóa và cung cấp cho chúng tôi một cách nhanh chóng để đạt được những gì chúng tôi đã đạt được một cách trực tiếp
với object.create, điều khiển chi tiết thủ công trong giải pháp hai của chúng tôi.
Chúng tôi thấy rằng từ khóa này và tất cả những điều thú vị, hoặc
hai cách thú vị mà nó hoạt động.
Chúng tôi đã thấy cách các hàm mũi tên có thể cung cấp cho chúng tôi nhiều quyền kiểm soát hơn đối với điều đó,
từ khóa này và đã đưa chúng ta đến hết phần cuối cùng,
vốn đang xây dựng lớp học từ đầu bằng cách sử dụng tất cả các phần này dưới mui xe.
Vì vậy, dân gian, đó là một niềm vui tuyệt đối.
Tôi thích làm điều này với tất cả các bạn.
Tôi nghĩ đó là nó.
Giả sử chúng tôi là một người kết thúc, 5:30, chúng tôi đã làm được.
Đó là một niềm vui.
Chúng tôi sẽ gặp lại tất cả các bạn [LAUGH] vào một ngày không xa.
Cảm ơn tất cả mọi người và cổ vũ.
>> Người nói 2: Tuyệt vời.
[VỖ TAY]